a recent study predicts thousands of
local jobs could just vanish to
automation and we've seen it you know
kiosks at restaurants robots serving
food checking into a hotel you can all
do that automated now as well las vegas
has the nation's highest percentage of
workers at high risk of being replaced
by technology hector mejia live in
person for us this morning with a look
at how this could impact our hospitality
industry hector good morning
good morning well that's exactly what
brought us out here the hospitality
industry embracing technology we see it
at the casino floors at the gaming
tables also those machines checking you
into the hotel rooms while the study
says
gaming dealers have a probability of
automation of 96 percent we've seen
technology pretty much happen everywhere
from robots and restaurants to cleaning
machines a whole range of tasks the
bottom line organizations making use of
technology to make things more
efficiently robots don't call in sick
don't need health care well the study by
commodity.com says more than 49 percent
of las vegas workers are at high risk of
automation while 42 percent of all u.s
workers face the same risk so we took
the study over to a local center where
we found two women searching for jobs
and this is their opinion about this
i think it's absolutely a crime because
it's just putting a lot of us that would
like to work out of jobs and then also
you want us to do it and then the
machines don't work even if you want to
be a cashier everything is computers
and for someone like myself i'm a senior
i thought i could work around it and you
can't it's there it's here to stay
and it is so researchers behind the
study looked at the latest data from the
u.s bureau of labor statistics as well
as information from the university of
oxford and at that local center we went
to they were already looking into this
studying the impact of automation here
locally you'll want to hear what they
have to say and also the resources that
they're providing out there that's still
ahead in the next half hour reporting
live hector mejia live local now